merci d'être avec nous Vincent Delahaye
et de nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure vous êtes sénateur
centriste de l'Essonne vice-président du
Sénat on va parler de l'augmentation du
prix des péages des autoroutes dans
quelques instants mais d'abord
évidemment la réforme des retraites
puisque c'est aujourd'hui le coup
d'envoi des débats à l'Assemblée
nationale et Elisabeth qui a déclaré
hier dans le Journal du Dimanche qu'elle
était prête à bouger elle a fait de
nouvelles propositions notamment sur les
carrières longues pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 20 et 21 ans
qui pourront partir à 63 ans est-ce que
dans l'état de ce que vous connaissez de
ce texte et avant évidemment ce qui ne
sortira de l'Assemblée c'est un texte
que vous pourriez voter écoutez moi je
pense d'abord qu'il faut une réforme des
retraites ce qui disent qu'il n'en faut
pas c'est des irresponsables donc il y
en a quand même quelques-uns mais
j'espère que ça sera pas une majorité
parce que honnêtement il y a nécessité
on peut pas continuer à avoir un système
de retraite qui qui fait peser tout sur
les jeunes générations et dont les
anciens aujourd'hui profitent donc moi
je pense qu'on a un bon système mais il
faut quand même le réformer
régulièrement
on peut toujours il y en a beaucoup de
réformes des retraites possibles il y a
beaucoup de situations différentes il y
a presque pas une situation
identique entre deux Français tout le
monde n'a pas cotisé la même chose
personne n'a même carrière donc c'est
c'est quand même très compliqué c'est un
sujet très très compliqué donc on peut
toujours trouver des défauts à tout et
moi je retrouverai j'aurais pas
forcément fait cette réforme là moi je
trouve que le totem de l'âge même si je
suis je suis pour un report de l'âge
mais le totem de l'âge n'est pas
forcément le bon critère parce que pour
moi c'est la durée de cotisation qui
devrait être le bon critère et on
devrait pouvoir ajouter 8 trimestres si
on veut rajouter deux ans on rajoute 8
trimestres mais ceux qui sont commencé à
travailler tôt par Toto ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tard par plus tard
ce qui me semble assez assez logique
assez juste donc moi je tout le monde ou
uniquement pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt le le les critères de la
durée de la durée pour tout le monde moi
pour moi ça serait pour tout le monde
donc bon voilà et il y a certaines
choses moi j'aurais sans doute de départ
mais vous augmenterez encore une durée
de cotisation j'aurais aussi sans doute
sollicité les retraités actuels
c'est-à-dire quand on fait une réforme
des retraites pour moi même si c'est pas
très populaire et politiquement c'est
assez difficile mais il faut il faut
faire des efforts sur les actifs il faut
faire des efforts aussi sur les
retraités donc on peut on peut faire une
indexation qui soit un petit peu moins
que l'inflation progressivement mais qui
montre que tout le monde fait des
efforts pour équilibrer le système parce
que si le système est pas équilibré
financièrement il est en sursis et en
danger donc il faut il faut y faire
attention juste parce que vous parlez
d'augmenter la durée de cotisation vous
parlez de 8 trimestre c'est-à-dire pour
vous il faut aller jusqu'à 45 à unités
vous gardez les 43 années 8 trimestre si
on passe de 62 à 64 ans ça fait 8
trimestres ça fait en gardant les 43
minutes et voilà bah oui tout à fait
pour vous il faut augmenter aussi le
nombre d'annuités alors il faut
augmenter moi je pense il faut augmenter
le nombre d'années
progressivement pas forcément
brutalement mais progressivement et pas
d'âge est-ce que il y a aussi des
questions qui se sur le moment qui a
choisi le gouvernement pour faire cette
réforme est-ce que c'était le bon moment
pour vous
quand on est contre c'est jamais le bon
moment quand on est pour ça vient jamais
assez vite donc après moi je pense qu'on
aurait pu le faire même pendant la
période de pandémie donc je pense pas
qu'il fallait reculer on peut gérer une
pandémie en même temps réformer
la réforme il faut la faire elle a été
promise par le Président de la
République en tout cas elle a été
annoncé il y a pas de surprise on prend
personne par surprise le gouvernement a
négocié après bien sûr bien entendu
qu'on peut trouver des choses à redire
des des choses encore à négocier ce que
ce que font les républicains l'Assemblée
nationale ils ont raison ils ont raison
c'est eux qui sont en position de faire
la majorité c'est normal qu'ils essayent
de pousser leur avantage entre
guillemets et essayer d'obtenir un
certain nombre de choses et montrer que
par leur existence ils ont réussi à
faire évoluer le projet si vous allez
chercher à obtenir des modifications
lesquels alors on n'a pas encore on n'a
pas encore décidé parce que ça dépendra
effectivement du texte qui va arriver de
l'Assemblée nationale de ce qui aura
déjà été voté à l'Assemblée nationale
donc c'est encore un peu tôt pour pour
vous dire lesquels
on le modifiera forcément on a
l'habitude de modifier les textes au
Sénat on aimerait que nos amendements
soient pris en compte un peu plus
fréquemment mais en tout cas c'est
quelque chose qu'on essaie de faire ici
c'est d'essayer de bonifier les textes
de rapporter des choses supplémentaires
je crois que c'est c'est est-ce que
c'est sur les carrières longues comme le
font les républiques
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à des
sanctions alors est-ce que tu vas voir
moi personnellement je non je vais pas
vous donner mon point de vue personnel
mais on en a pas encore vraiment discuté
je préfère pas m'engager là dessus
sur un dernier mot sur ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée puisque on l'a dit à un coup
d'envoi des débats à 16h 18000
amendements étaient déposés juste par la
nuque 18000 juste par la nuque
alors
18000 par la nuque et 20000 en tout
parce qu'il y a aussi des amendements de
renaissance de la majorité et des
républicains est-ce que la nuque avec
ses 18000 amendements vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne stratégie est-ce qu'elle
a raison de se faire entendre la raison
se faire entendre ça c'est vrai mais moi
je suis pas pour la multiplication des
amendements je pense que à un moment
donné ça c'est c'est plus encondable que
on se concentre sur un certain nombre
d'amendement majeur que quand on
souhaite faire passer là là c'est c'est
l'obstruction la stratégie de
l'obstruction c'est pas une bonne
stratégie je pense pas pour un
parlementaire il faut d'abord travailler
sur le fond et à partir du moment on est
d'accord sur le fond moi je c'est au
Sénat je plaide pour ça aussi je plaide
pour qu'il y ait moins d'amendements
mais de meilleurs amendements qu'on est
bien travaillé à l'avance et qu'il soit
bien identifiable par les médias et puis
par le public
on va parler du prix des autoroutes et
de l'augmentation des péages des
autoroutes PC évidemment un sujet qui
concerne et qui inquiète de nombreux
Français 4,75% en moyenne en premier
février et c'est pas sans susciter
évidemment colère et contestation on
fait le point d'abord avec Alex Moussa
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour et Alex
l'augmentation des tarifs des péages des
autoroutes à partir du 1er février fait
polémique effectivement une hausse de
4,75% à partir du 1er février en moyenne
pour les péages d'autoroute c'est une
hausse qui s'explique par l'inflation
généralisée qui a 6% en moyenne et
d'ailleurs le prix des péages est indexé
sur le taux d'inflation le problème
c'est que les sociétés privées qui
gèrent ces autoroutes se portent très
bien sur le plan financier en 2021 ces
sociétés concessionnaires ont réalisé un
bénéfice net de 3,9 milliards d'euros un
bénéfice en hausse de plus 47% par
rapport à 2020 qui était une année assez
faible sur le trafic autoroutier mais
par exemple par rapport à 2019 et bien
c'est une hausse de 11% donc voilà une
forte rentabilité pour ces sociétés et
avec cette rentabilité hors norme elle
avait été dénoncée en 2020 par la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur la
privatisation des autoroutes mais oui
une commission d'enquête du Sénat dont
vous étiez le rapporteur Vincent delay
vous aviez par exemple auditionné
Dominique de qui était premier ministre
au moment de la privatisation des
autoroutes en 2006 ou encore Ségolène
Royal auditionné au Sénat car en 2015 et
bien elle avait sous le gouvernement de
François Hollande elle avait négocié un
accord de gel des tarifs d'autoroute et
au final votre rapport le rapport de la
commission d'enquête avait prévu une
surentabilité une rentabilité de 40
milliards d'euros d'ici à 2036 date de
la fin de ses concessions de ces
sociétés d'autoroute et c'est méga
profit des sociétés concessionnaires et
bien ils ont été aussi récemment pointés
du doigt par le gendarme des autoroutes
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
qui préconisent des mesures à prendre
pour les futurs concessions
autoroutières selon ce rapport et bien
il faudra mettre un terme à l'indexation
des tarifs de PA sur l'inflation il
faudra également raccourcir à 15 ans
maximum la durée des concessions
accordées par l'État et puis aussi
rétrécir le périmètre géographique de
ces concessions autoroutières impérimée
qui est très étendu actuellement
également Vincent Delahaye d'abord sur
cette hausse actuelle des péages plus
virgule plus
4,75%, c'est excessif selon vous écoutez
vous avez dit que elles étaient en bonne
santé ces sociétés qu'elles avaient une
surentabilité
l'augmentation de 4,75% va leur
rapporter 500 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires supplémentaires par
an jusqu'à la fin des contrats et on
peut penser que l'inflation qui joue sur
les dépenses d'exploitation de ces
sociétés va leur coûter 200 millions
donc entre 500 et 200 millions il y a
300 millions 300 millions de marches
supplémentaires alors qu'on dit qu'elles
sont déjà en bonne santé qu'elles ont
sur rentabilité donc on va leur donner
300 millions supplémentaires par an
jusqu'à la fin des contrats je trouve
que c'est très excessif c'est très très
excessif alors bien entendu on va on va
dire sceller contrats on les applique
depuis le début le problème c'est les
contrats quand vous faites une
concession il faut avoir un bon contrat
il faut avoir un bon suivi au départ on
a une ni l'un ni l'autre alors
maintenant on a un meilleur suivi mais
on a toujours des mauvais contrats
ils ont été mal négociés non c'est
qu'ils ont été négociés par l'État avec
lui-même à l'origine donc quand on veut
négocier un contrat avec soi-même on le
fait surtout pour la forme en réalité il
aurait fallu les modifier avant
l'ouverture privée c'est Jospin qui a
commencé en 2002 à ouvrir au privé 20 %
de des Autoroutes du Sud de la France et
ensuite Dominique de Villepin qui a fait
le reste et c'est vrai que c'est à ce
moment-là qu'il aurait fallu modifier
ses contrats mais il n'est pas trop tard
il n'est pas trop tard pour le faire
s'il y a une vraie volonté on peut les
modifier simplement on sent pas la
volonté de la part du gouvernement de
s'emparer vraiment de ce sujet moi je
pense que c'est un sujet majeur
d'intérêt pour les automobiles
automobilistes et aussi pour l'intérêt
général de l'État donc on peut
renégocier ces contrats sans attendre la
fin des concessions en 2036 vous savez
quand on est accrocédant on a toujours
des relations avec les concessionnaires
qui sont les sociétés le Conseil dense
et l'État et l'État peut être assez fort
pour dire venez autour de la table et on
va discuter parce que on peut pas
continuer comme cela simplement il faut
avoir la volonté si on n'a pas la
volonté et si les sociétés ne sont pas
cette volonté forte il ne se passe rien
et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les sociétés
disent à vous toucher une virgule vous
touchez l'équilibre du contrat ça va pas
on leur baisse le taux de d'impôt sur
les sociétés pacael c'est une façon
générale on a baissé de 33 25% elles
vont quand même encaisser 7 milliards
d'euros grâce à cela d'ici la fin des
contrats 7 milliards d'euros et il s'est
rien passé et le contrat et là ils sont
en train de contester auprès auprès de
la justice le fait qu'on ait indexé sur
l'inflation les taxes d'aménagement
rendez compte elle touche d'un côté 7
milliards et de l'autre côté on dit on
va indexer des des petites taxes
d'aménagement sur l'inflation et elles
vont devant le tribunal moi je trouve ça
scandaleux honnêtement je serai le
ministre des Transports je peux vous
dire je les convocerai tout de suite et
ça se passerait pas comme cela pourquoi
pourquoi il le fait pas parce qu'il y a
pas la volonté je pense qu'il y a comme
je j'ai l'habitude de le dire quand il y
a la volonté il y a un chemin et là en
fait on sent pas de volonté du tout de
la part du gouvernement bon ils ont ils
ont d'autres sujets on parlait des
retraites à l'instant mais c'est pas
parce qu'on a un ou deux sujets autres
qu'il faut pas traiter aussi des sujets
comme celui-là c'est un manque de
volontaire c'est un manque de courage
politique
il faut aussi avoir du courage politique
et puis mettre autour de la table des
partenaires comme on l'a demandé au
Sénat nous ce que l'on a obtenu au Sénat
quand même la commission d'enquête il
faut le redire il faut le redire à tous
ceux qui nous écoutent c'est qu'on a
obtenu qu'il n'y ait plus de prorogation
de ces mauvais contrats parce que c'est
mauvais contrats ils étaient projetés
vous avez parlé de 2015 c'était Ségolène
Royal et Emmanuel Macron les deux qui
ont signé un protocole d'accord avec les
saucisses d'autoroutes et ça avait déjà
été fait auparavant où on leur demande
des travaux supplémentaires donc leur
demander 4 milliards de travaux
supplémentaires et on disait vous allez
avoir entre deux et quatre ans de plus
de contrats mais deux et quatre ans de
plus de contrat ça leur rapporte
beaucoup plus que les 4 milliards qui
vont dépenser en travaux donc il y a un
moment donné il faut arrêter cette
logique là cette ce cycle infernal de
prorogation et donc c'est ce qu'on a
obtenu grâce à notre rapport au Sénat
parce qu'il y avait il y avait encore
des projets dans les tiroirs du
ministère et depuis vous avez vu qu'il
s'est rien passé et je pense qu'il se
passera rien sur le terme de la
prorogation maintenant ce qu'il faut
obtenir c'est la modification de ces
contrats donc il faut pouvoir se mettre
autour de la table ce qu'on a demandé et
moi ce que je vais redemander au
gouvernement et il faut continuer à
mettre de la pression c'est-à-dire que
les médias comme vous vous participez
aussi à cette pression et nous les
parlementaires on a intérêt aussi à
continuer à en parler et à faire en
sorte que ce sujet là ne soit pas
enterré et en cas d'échec de
renégociation de ces contrats on peut
envisager une taxe sur ses profits
autoroutiers c'est compliqué parce que
sur le plan constitutionnel on va avoir
du mal à cibler uniquement certaines
sociétés certains en plus qui ont des
contrats avec les tasses c'est c'est
quand même assez compliqué je pense que
ça serait pas acceptable donc moi je
pense que c'est une renégociation
d'ensemble qu'il faut obtenir à défaut
faudra peut-être aller plus loin donc
moi je suis en train de réfléchir à des
mesures plus plus coercitives je suis en
train de y réfléchir donc mais je
j'aurai l'occasion d'en faire de faire
des propositions au printemps je pense
d'abord on va regarder les résultats de
cette année parce que vous avez parlé de
2021 à 3,9 milliards mais on va avoir le
9 février les résultats de Vinci et puis
sans doute vers le 20 février les
résultats des phages donc j'aurai
l'occasion de remettre à jour nos
prévisions ce qu'on avait on avait fait
des prévisions et si on écoutait les
sociétés d'autoroute on en parlera
jamais parce que à chaque fois qu'il
vous donne une information c'est couvert
par le secret des affaires donc c'est
quand même assez assez ahurissant qu'un
sujet aussi intéressant pour le public
puisse être systématiquement en dehors
de la transparence et autres alors il y
a aussi une solution toute simple et qui
serait assez forte et qui était proposée
pendant la dernière campagne
présidentielle ce serait de
renationaliser ses autoroutes ça peut
être la bonne solution peut selon vous
si vous me trouvez un service de l'État
qui est bien géré ou des infrastructures
qui sont bien gérées par l'état des
équipements vous me le dites l'État ne
serait pas à même de gérer les
autoroutes l'État est mauvais
gestionnaire si vous regardez les
hôpitaux vous allez pas me dire que les
hôpitaux sont super bien gérés donc on a
un état qui malheureusement n'est pas un
bon gestionnaire donc il est pas
question pour moi en tout cas il est pas
souhaitable que l'on renationalise les
autoroutes par contre
le système de la concession est un bon
système pour moi puisque on peut avoir
des sociétés qui sont très compétentes
et elles sont compétentes on a des
bonnes autoroutes elles sont en bon état
il y a des niveaux de service qui est
très satisfaisant par rapport à ce qui
peut se passer à l'étranger donc il y a
pas de raison de perdre ce niveau de
service par contre par contre il faut
effectivement les serrer de près serré
de près au niveau du contrat et dans le
suivi régulier c'est à dire qu'on a des
clauses de revoyure quand on a des
contrats un peu long il faut avoir des
clauses de revoyure régulière où on se
remet autour de la table on dit est-ce
que vous avez gagné plus moi comment ça
se passe et on regarde tout ça donc
c'est c'est tout cela qui a pas été fait
et c'est ça qu'il faut faire juste parce
que la relation vous dit de moyen un
problème de l'État gestionnaire Clément
bon il dit c'est aussi un problème de
finance 50 milliards alors ça ça peut
être on n'en sait rien en fait on n'en
sait rien parce que il y a moyen de
négocier l'équilibre économique et
financier de ces contrats n'a jamais été
défini donc nous on demande à ce qu'il
soit défini parce que c'est c'est
l'élément central sont un contrat c'est
c'est l'équilibre du contrat et eux ils
disent dès qu'on met une virgule en
question en on supprime on met en cause
l'équilibre moi je pense que il faut
qu'on se mette autour de la table pour
définir cet équilibre là et si on
définit cette équilibre on va
s'apercevoir que contrairement à ce que
dit la RT parce que je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec les
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
qui calcule à une rentabilité sur le
projet moi je calcule une rentabilité
pour l'actionnaire l'actionner les
actionnaires sont arrivés à un moment
donné ils ont mis tant d'argent sur la
table qu'est-ce que ça leur apporte et
quel taux de rentabilité et aujourd'hui
le taux de rentabilité de 8% qui est
quand même un gros taux un taux
important en tout cas va être atteint en
2023 ou 2024 donc c'est d'ailleurs plus
de 10 ans avant la fin des contrats donc
c'est là où on dit tout ce qui est après
c'est l'assurantalité ça va au-delà des
8% j'espère avoir découvert oui mais
surtout on va continuer à en parler
Alexa tout à l'heure
ce sera à suivre on continue à parler
des autoroutes on va aller dans votre
département on va à Ris-Orangis on
retrouve tes divoris bonjour Teddy merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous rédacteur en
chef du Républicain de l'Essonne vous
souhaitez vous aussi revenir sur cette
question des autoroutes avec une
augmentation des prix qui impacte
particulièrement les automobilistes de
l'Essonne dites-nous pourquoi
effectivement les autoroutes A10 et à 11
dans leur tronçons périurbains sont
également payants en Île-de-France et
donc en Essonne et effectivement
le tarif pour Vinci puisque c'est le
concessionnaire pour ces deux axes va
augmenter le plus de 5%. alors
heureusement les concessionnaires sont
très généreux et la petite histoire pour
les usagers quotidiens l'axe augmenter
de 10 % malheureusement ça semble quand
même un peu faible par rapport aux
chiffres de la rentabilité que vous
aviez évoqué plutôt et qui sont valables
également pour ainsi et donc la question
qu'on peut se poser pour lesquelles
notamment l'association à 10-28 c'est
est-ce que les trous sont pour urbains
des autres gratuits en plus que ça
n'apporterait pas de manière majeure
l’équilibre financiers du
concessionnaire qu'en pensez-vous
monsieur le sénateur
bonjour Ted
nous on est tout à fait d'accord et moi
j'étais d'accord on l'a repris dans
notre rapport de commission d'enquête
c'est vrai que le sur la 10 le pH est un
effectivement à des rares péages urbains
qu'on ne connaît pas beaucoup d'autres
en France et il est contesté depuis
longtemps en fait il reporte le trafic
notamment une partie du trafic poids
lourd sur la N20 et la N20 était sur
encombrée de cette là donc je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui rapporte à peu
près 40 millions de chiffre d'affaires
par an ce
péage et que il y a matière à négocier
quand on regarde les 40 milliards qui
ont été évoqués tout à l'heure de
surentabilité il y a moyen de trouver
dans ces 40 milliards 40 millions
qui puissent alors c'est 40 millions par
an donc ça ça il faudrait les multiplier
par 10 ça fait quand même un petit peu
plus mais en tout cas il y a moyen de
trouver
un accord pour pour ce péage
qui est géré par Vinci depuis très
longtemps et sans doute l'une des plus
rentables des autoroutes les plus
rentables avec les Autoroutes du Sud de
la France le tronçon au kilomètre le
plus cher de France si je me souviens
bien et alors moi ce qui me marque c'est
que le gouvernement dit toujours j'ai
beaucoup négocié quoi le ministre il dit
j'ai beaucoup négocié avec Vinci j'ai
obtenu le fait que sur des parcours de
courte distance on n'est pas
d'augmentation mais en fait on ne sait
même pas ce que ça représente j'ai dit
tout à l'heure que l'augmentation de
4,75% ça faisait pour les sociétés
d'autoroute 300 millions de marge
supplémentaires de marge supplémentaire
qu'est-ce que représente leur gestes par
rapport à ces 300 millions on sait même
pas on sait même pas si ça représente 30
millions c'est même pas 10% de cette
marge on ne sait pas il y a pas de
transparence du tout donc on a besoin
sur le sujet d'avoir de la transparence
et de continuer les combats pour la
gratuité de la 10
on va parler d'un autre sujet on va
parler des sénatoriales puisque
s'approche et oui c'est en septembre
votre département est renouvelable et on
va faire un point que vous êtes dit
effectivement c'est au mois de septembre
c'est encore loin je sais qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de travail parlementaire
à mener mais dans nos colonnes la
semaine dernière
leçon
évoquait la nécessité pour les élus
sortants de la droite et du centre de
créer les conditions d'une union
qui permettrait de garantir trois sièges
même dans les espérer un quatrième lors
du scrutin éviter que la droite et le
centre ne redevienne minoritaire en
Essonne alors est-ce que c'est une
analyse que vous partagez monsieur de
l'AS nécessitait de créer une liste de
numéros écoutez c'est compliqué de créer
une union parce que il y a toujours des
des personnes qui souhaitent se
présenter vous savez au sénatorial il y
a toujours moi ça va être ma quatrième
campagne il y a toujours pas mal de
liste et il y a des surprises toujours
des gens qui auraient bien été sur une
liste et qui finalement n'y sont pas et
décide d'y aller donc c'est un petit peu
compliqué la dernière fois il y avait
pas d'union il y avait deux listes qui
ont permis de faire quatre sénateur sur
5 donc il y a pas de il y a pas de
système parfait pour pour garantir une
un nombre de sièges moi je pense que sur
le département la gauche a regagné
quelques positions au moment des
municipales notamment au détriment de LR
des républicains donc voilà moi je suis
ouvert à toutes les discussions donc je
suis pas du tout fermé je pense pas
qu'il y ait une solution idéale pour
faire le maximum de siège en tout cas
pour ma part je vais essayer de le faire
je pense avoir bien travaillé on forme
une bonne équipe avec Jocelyne guidez
donc je moi je resterai fidèle à
Jocelyne guidez
parce que certains me disent ah bah
Jocelyne tu pourras peut-être laisser
ben non moi je suis pour l'amitié la
fidélité
elle m'a suivi depuis 2011 j'ai envie de
continuer avec elle donc ce qui me ce
qui me conseillent ou qui me demandent
d'éventuellement de la laisser ne pas
repartir ou repartir un peu loin sur la
liste moi je ne suis pas d'accord
le message est passé c'est clair on a
bien compris que vous êtes candidat à
votre succession du coup Teddy c'est bon
une autre question ou c'est clair c'est
clair il faut dire merci beaucoup Teddy
là de l'Essonne cette semaine un nouveau
visage pour le lycée de ris c'est à la
Une de votre journal merci beaucoup
Teddy d'avoir été bonne journée on va
parler d'un autre sujet on parle
beaucoup de l'inflation des normes
l'inflation des lois et vous vous
travaillez justement sur ce sujet dans
le cadre d'une mission balai on va dire
ça comme ça en quoi ça consiste
un acronyme bureau d'abongation des lois
anciennes inutiles donc j'ai trouvé ça
donc je suis devenu le roi du balai et
non j'avais proposé quand j'étais
justement candidat au sénatorial de je
trouve qu'il y a trop de textes en
France on sait même pas combien il y en
a en fait il y en a plus de 10000 10
11000 on sait pas très bien donc j'avais
souhaité que on
[Musique]
ça veut dire que les textes du 19e
siècle
on abordait partie de 1820 à peu près et
à l'époque les lois c'était une
demi-page c'était une demi-page parfois
une page et aujourd'hui vous avez
parfois 350 pages de loi donc vous voyez
un peu l'inflation l'inflation des
textes donc on a on a supprimé cela
alors ce qu'on a supprimé c'est des
choses faciles c'est par exemple la
création de la taxe professionnelle la
taxe professionnelle a été supprimée
mais en fait le texte correspondant n'a
pas été supprimé donc il faut le
nettoyer la conscription pour la guerre
d'Algérie
il y a pas mal il y a pas mal de choses
qui sont des des vieux textes qui ne
sont plus
usités par contre il faudrait continuer
maintenant alors là je continue parce
que je vais en déposer balai trois au
printemps mais mon souhait c'est qu'on
aille plus loin qu'on aille aussi dans
le travail de cohérence des textes les
uns avec les autres puisque vous savez
que les textes de loi sont répartis
ensuite dans des codes code civils code
pénal le code des collectivités
territoriales et parfois les mêmes
textes sont dans plusieurs codes et ils
sont pas forcément cohérents donc on a
un travail de cohérence et de lisibilité
de la loi qui est très importante et ce
sera au printemps voilà vous reviendrez
nous en parler merci merci de m'avoir
invité merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires évidemment on reparlera de
la réforme des retraites puisque le
débat commence aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale et
on va en parler avec notre prochaine
invité c'est Claude malurey qui nous
rejoint